Long have I waited.
and now
you're coming together
is your undoing. welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going to be my non-spoilery
Star Wars Episode 9 rise of Skywalker
review so no worries no spoilers in this
video if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything I'll
be doing all my easter egg videos and my
full review all that stuff later this
week after everyone has a chance to
watch the movie so if you do have a
chance to see the movie early please
don't post spoilers on this video but we
have to talk about the maximum Star Wars
movie there is more Star Wars in rise of
Skywalker than in any other Star Wars
movie you've ever seen what does that
mean to have the most Star Wars in your
Star Wars movie well this is the last
film in the skywalker saga of films the
films that primarily follow the
Skywalker family a long time ago George
Lucas said to Star Wars when he was
talking about his films were about a
family following them through the
generations the Skywalker family people
of Skywalker blood you start with Anakin
Skywalker in the prequels he becomes
Darth Vader then you follow his children
Luke and Leia in the classic films now
you're following the next generation in
the new films so a lot of the movie is
dedicated to telling that family's story
what does family mean what does it mean
to be part of that Skywalker family what
is their legacy going to be those were
just some of the bigger questions that
they had to answer in the movie but the
movie itself is dedicated to answering
all of your fan questions so a lot of
people will come out of the movie
calling it the most fanservice
Star Wars movie of all the saga films
but I definitely think
that a lot of it was made with the
intention of addressing some of the
biggest complaints people have had about
Star Wars Force awakens and Star Wars
the last Jedi we got one last chance to
do this let's try to make them as happy
as possible and get them ready for
whatever's coming next one of the things
I was happy to see in the things that
you Star Wars youtubers will enjoy is
that it does set up a lot of new things
that they'll have to explore in the new
Star Wars movies set after the events of
rise of Skywalker
they'll keep making movies set in the
past they're currently developing a
Knights of the Old Republic movie but
most of their energy is based on
developing new story with new characters
sets forward in the timeline moving this
giant ship forward praise be to baby
Yoda who will be there hopefully to
witness all that
if you didn't like a lot of the major
canonical choices of Star Wars last Jedi
you will probably be one of the people
that likes Star Wars rise of Skywalker a
little more it didn't completely retcon
a lot of the major choices and twists of
last Jedi but it does throw it a little
bit under the bus I'll discuss how it
does that later in a more nuanced
detailed way and my full spoiler review
and breakdown videos later this week it
starts a little all over the place in
the first act it's like the beginning of
Star Wars rogue one and then there are
some parts that are a little bit silly
for my taste in what you would normally
treat is a big serious Star Wars movie
it is meant to be the final movie in the
Skywalker saga so you expected to treat
things pretty seriously but JJ Abrams
the screenwriters and everyone tried to
deliver on every big question every fan
wish you've ever had watching all total
nine of these Star Wars saga films so it
spends way more of its time trying to be
a fan pleaser than something like last
Jedi which spent most of its time trying
to upend the major tropes of the
franchise that's why you've probably
seen a lot of people who liked last
Jedi's speaking poorly of rise of
Skywalker as much as things jump around
so much during the first act of the film
I feel like the whole second half of the
film will be what most people are
talking about that's really when the
film starts to take off longtime fans of
the franchise will be happy with a lot
of the stuff that they tried to include
and re canonize from Star Wars legends
so if you're not familiar with the
expanded universe there was a whole
swath of published material starting in
the 90s of all this expanded Star Wars
Canon when there weren't any new Star
Wars films when Disney bought the
franchise they sort of swept that under
the rug so shadows of the Empire the
great Timothy Zahn Thrawn Trilogy
all the Dark Horse comic books
everything kind of got swept under the
rug and they just decided to start with
Clone Wars the animated series and then
Star Wars rebels is sort of their
expanded Canon but slowly and slowly
they've started to bring stuff back from
legends and put it in the new TV shows
in the new movies so there are a lot of
really really deep cuts a lot of really
cool force lore and Sith Lore so if
you're really into that aspect of Star
Wars you will like some of the stuff
they included in the movie but unlike
force awakens I feel like this is them
kind of addressing one of the major
complaints of that film it's not a
complete remake of a
earlier Star Wars movie there's a lot of
places and a lot of beats that feel
familiar to return to the Jedi but it's
not as straight up a remake as force
awakens was talking about all the actors
Adam driver as kylo Ren has been one of
the secret weapons of the modern Star
Wars films he's on fire as always during
the movie Daisy Ridley and he were great
together Finn and Poe were great
together in this movie I've been a fan
of Oscar Isaacs now for a while he's
great they also sort of corrected the
mistakes of the earlier films and gave
Poe way more story in this they used him
so heavily in the force awakens
marketing and then he had like a couple
minutes during the film and that was it
they gave him a little more to do during
last Jedi I'm Way happier with what they
did with his character during rise of
Skywalker in same thing with john
boyega's character i feel like his
performance and what they did with his
character in rise of skywalker is way
better than the other two films because
this is a non-spoilery review i can't
say too much about carrie fisher's
scenes but most you probably know that
because she passed away before they
started shooting the film all the
footage of Carrie Fisher in the movie is
actually reworked deleted scenes from
force awakens but it totally worked for
me there wasn't any kind of uncanny
valley issues or anything like that you
will be thinking about it in the theater
though if you remember that she's
actually passed away before they shot
this film you will be thinking about
that a little bit but they did a great
job of honoring her character and
memorializing the classic trilogy
characters talking about some of the new
characters Keri Russell as Zori bliss
was fantastic she's that helmeted
character you've been seeing all the
marketing you've probably seen some of
the footage in the trailers of that tiny
alien engineer his name is Babu Frick
he's great during the movie they
actually tried to give c-3po a real art
during this film so they make him way
more critical to the actual plot during
this movie the pacing is way better in
this film that it was during last Jedi
also probably force awakens some will
argue that it moves too quickly because
they cram so much plot and story into
this small movie it's shorter than last
Jedi but they're telling way more actual
story I expected that going into the
movie so it wasn't that big of a
surprise because there's just so many
questions and character arch that they
have to wrap up
remember how Avengers endgame was over
three hours long imagine what that movie
would have felt like in terms of pacing
if they had cut another 20 to 25 minutes
of the movie out so some of the other
critics that I saw at the premiere the
complained that it didn't give you
enough time to linger on some of the
more interesting moments especially
earlier in the film like a good example
during force awakens at the beginning is
when you first meet the Rey character on
jakku you spend several minutes
following her through her daily routine
just getting to know her now in rise of
skywalker there's none of that they hit
the ground running big time
they cut from scene to scene way way
faster and it leaves you the fan to fill
in some of the gaps yourself but it
doesn't yada-yada-yada its way through
the important things nearly as badly as
Game of Thrones did so the rapid cuts
didn't bother me that much all the mains
get much clearer story arcs there's way
more of the new Trinity of characters
together Rey Finn and Poe something
people complained last Jedi lacked
without talking too much about it though
I do feel like there going to be a couple
really controversial twists in the movie
I'm going to have to see it a couple more
times to decide how I feel about it
especially the ending I mean of course
the ending was always going to be
controversial this is the last film in a nine film saga it won't be quite as
controversial as Game of Thrones ending
but still a really big twist that I did
not see coming so I'll wait to talk
about that till I post my full spoiler
review later this week there are a
couple big plot twists that the film
turns on that it's going to take a while to
unpack the music was fantastic as always
it's probably my favorite soundtrack of
all the new Star Wars movies and within
that probably some of my favorite tracks
were when it goes to really dark sith
places enjoy it while it lasts because
it's the last time Jon Williams said he
would do music for Star Wars movie but I
think the idea is is that future movies
will always have remixed elements of the
original John Williams music it's so
iconic it's become endemic to Star Wars
stories even a series like the
Mandalorian which is kind of a space
Western which has a totally different
composer working on and at a totally
different style takes a lot of
inspiration from the classical John
Williams music the cinematography and
all the technical aspects of the film
were great Star Wars movies typically
always look great usually when people
complain about Star Wars it's about the
characters or the story I feel like
everyone mostly agrees that the set
design the aliens the special effects
the costumes are always really polished
I've only seen the movie once so I'm not
quite ready to rank it with all the other new films
be sure to go see the movie when you have a chance so you ask after this movie
what's going to happen next what do we have to look forward to the next couple of
years well a lot more baby Yoda the
Mandalorian season 2 will release next
year around the same time there's the
obi-wan Kenobi series that they're
working on next year the rogue one
prequel series there's rumors of another
secret Star Wars Disney Plus series that
they're working on Star Wars Episode 10
isn't dated until December 2022 so it'll
be about three years before we get
another Star Wars movie so praise be to
baby Yoda who will carry us through the
dark but what's going to happen next is is
my Mandalorian episode 7 video will post
later today that's right they posted the
episode early so that it's not
conflicting with the release of rise of
Skywalker this weekend while you wait
for that click here for my Mandalorian
episode 6 video
And Click here for my new Baby Yoda video.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome, and I'll see you guys tonight!
new baby Yoda video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight!